show us your hand show us some proof it
was both just to make sure yes we wanted
to know a little bit about what is going
on in the life of Daniel listing right
now how is quarantine going where are
you who are you with and how's it going
I'm in Los Angeles
I'm with Nadia why yes and you know
we're just kind of like we're laying low
we're looking after ourselves we're
looking after our neighbors the hardest
thing with this thing is just being
productive in a way if you can't you
know work for a paycheck so so that's
been a challenge for us is to sort of
stay stimulated how is it going at home
because I know you're busy Nadia's busy
but now you're really getting a taste of
what life is like when you're together
24/7 it's great it's easy you know I
would say that our relationship is
expanding to just better and better
places we've naughty or not we're really
funny because we're spending so much
time together better ways to communicate
with each other we're able to give each
other space
within within our house when when we
need it but also not sweating the small
stuff because when you're when you're in
like a confined space little things can
become way bigger than they actually are
and because there's nothing else to
really focus your energy on little
arguments can like escalate with
everyone
what kind of actually enjoying like
laughing at ourselves when we get you
know pissed off about you know whatever
if you can't take Nadia on these amazing
whirlwind trips that you guys do if you
can't go to the beach and you keep the
wine tasting how do you keep the romance
alive at home we've had a couple
blowouts dance parties at home as well
you know it gets nice one buddy's really
into - Elliot tomorrow which is forget
about it
we're getting a nice beautiful bottle of
red we're sitting there and then we got
a little back courtyard area listen Don
Draper celli we dressed up you know
we've put on like some nice clothes
we we made a meal together we you know
made some house homemade cocktails and
we we had like a date night like that we
couldn't effort in as well sort of you
know do do little thing for each other
that just to break the monotony a little
bit as well for example you know will
order little gifts online and like hide
around the house or something you know I
said this is president in some way
you're gonna have to find you got it
tell me what are they I love an online
purchase during quarantine what are
these things you're ordering and
surprising each other with little Sony's
little fluffy slippers uh t-shirts what
else did we get anything yeah anything
you want to show us new brush brush is
that not for her for you I don't really
I kind of like did a little bit that's
just being pushy mess I actually shaved
as well like well include clip it like
half an hour ago as well so you should
have say me about narrow guy well okay
that brings me into my next question did
you shave for this et interview are you
are you taking glam only seriously when
you know you have to do things like this
of course yes I'm letting myself go I'm
getting skinny in all the wrong places
and fat in all the wrong places
is there a pair of sweatpants on
underneath
I don't what not just a pair of like you
know shorts you see my shorts yeah I did
the casual but I am curious has Nadia
trimmed your hair have you done anything
for her she doesn't come my hair and I
haven't cut her hair but she can't go to
the beautician or anything like that
right and so I've been apparently I'm
good at it I've been doing the eyebrow
shaping and plucking you know see there
right and then giving like mini facials
and things like that you know and we you
know we we kind of do things like that I
have painted her nails and all that you
know I'm just doing it man
first time I did it I my nearly took too
much off and she could feel it she was
like whoa whoa whoa let's just have a
look okay stop there because you're
getting too into this you're gonna be
great husband and a great father someday
say well that brings me to my next
question you know my heart goes out to
all the brides and grooms who are
planning weddings for this year next
year and everything's been put on hold
so I know what is the status of the
wedding that you told ET that you were
planning for September in Bali right so
we postponed everything is is on for now
it is we've got everything on hold I
mean that's that's the smartest thing to
do for us right now we don't want to
pick a date and then have to I think
yeah exactly how are you guys doing how
did you react when you came to that
conclusion that we got a we got a pump
the brakes
well is an easy decision because we
don't risk the health and safety of our
friends and family we're pretty
philosophical about these kind of things
you know I think that if we worry about
the things that are within our control
and then don't sweat the stuff that's
out of our control this whole thing is
out of our control you know and so we
gotta roll with it is there a plan B
like are you guys thinking of new ideas
or new destinations at this point why
not no okay you're set on Bali I think
we are yeah I think we are really yeah
it's it's just one of those things look
you know we got a along with our theory
is we have a really long life together
and so you know it's all good it's all
good
I do have to tell you I am an Instagram
two-deck detective haha I notice our
Queen Nadia her name on her Instagram is
not a
listen so I'm wondering if if congrats
are in order if you maybe already tied
the knot I think this is great
pre-empting pre-empting the the marriage
okay and also this is just Nadia before
so she had to throw something in there
okay so she's just getting a jumpstart
on branding as a power couple
sure show us your hand show us some
proof it was both just to make sure that
a lot of my friends who have had to
postpone weddings they have said you
know what my date is sacred whether or
not I have a wedding I'm getting married
on November 5th and if it means I have a
rabbi or a priest in my backyard my
partner and I are tying the knot that
day and when we get to celebrate some
day down the road that will be a great
day is that something that you guys are
exploring we we have a date you know
we're looking at something next year a
date that's you know important to us but
but for our big family wedding why is
the date important to you you know it
might be the date that we met probably
made you I want to ask you because you
told me during our last interview thank
you writing a song
- perhaps perform at your wedding for
Nadia
I get goosebumps every time I think
about it because it's just the most
romantic thing in the world yeah have
you that song I kind of put it on hold
because I knew that we have it like
another year and I want it to be precone
as well when I say in to her well it's
kind of like you know an acoustic guitar
sing a song right it kind of stuff maybe
like it ed sheeran kind of vibe but a
little maybe a little more country
something I don't know what it is well I
kind of funky I suppose is there I'm I
don't know exactly what to call yet I
mean I could call it a number of things
but let's just call it Nadia finet so
sweet I love it I want to know who are
you in touch with have you spoken with
any of your rookie cast mates I'm your
one calls the heart cast mates yeah I
speak to air and occasionally just you
know what's that we sort of stay in
touch every couple of weeks check in
whatever well do you see Aaron's brownie
baking video oh yeah you did see it it's
a little bits of it yeah yeah yeah what
was your reaction it was good knowing
something I will defend Aaron through
and through that she tried her hardest
and if she would have kept it in for
maybe a five-ish more minutes those
would have been the best brownies of
life totally exactly
okay so what are you up to this weekend
the private training thing right yeah
this weekend could work great but also
we should eat can't learn on an empty
stomach
you're a straight man who plays a gay
character on television what is that
well I just feel like you know in if we
if we're making television shows and
films we able nowadays in particular
just just allow audiences to hear the
voice of a whole bunch of diverse
characters I think it's important for
for us to hear the stories and hear the
voices of people from all different
walks of lives races religion sexual
orientations you know I think that's
important for the collective psyche of
viewers you know I mean everyone loves
the show and people are really invested
in that sterling Jackson in storyline so
as a fan I think we'd really love to see
you return is there any chatter have
there been any conversations look I
Tidus is a friend of mine you know and
so we he's really loving the storyline
and as one of the lead actors on the
show he's you know fighting for that to
continue I think that's a really
positive sign that we can we can
continue the story yeah hey Titus the
fans want to see more so this is asking
Titus to please continue with it
[Music]